joined by candace owens candace you're
our newest colleague here at the daily
wire
we're excited to have you my first
question is
i know you've only been here for a few
days but
who's your favorite co-worker here at
daily wire that is a really good
question
um i'm going to have to go ahead and say
the makeup artists
as long as you didn't say michael
knowles one of the other hosts that's
right that's what i was worried about
uh how do you say you just you got to
tennessee i talked to you all fair
last week and you were talking about
your your experience driving here with a
baby
um and yeah i did that with four kids so
i know a little bit about that
you've been to texas have you
assimilated into the culture yet i mean
the
pickup truck the uh cowboy boots and all
that have you done that
yeah absolutely so that was actually the
first day second day at tennessee my
husband was like we're doing two things
we're going to the gun shop
and we're going to go buy a pair of
cowboy boots gun shop didn't go well
because
we still have our dc driver's license so
you have to have a tennessee license to
buy a gun so we still have to wait for
that
but it wasn't difficult to assimilate
into the culture because i think
actually that was my culture like i'm
conservative right so i was actually a
fish out of water living in dc
here i'm like this is great everybody
thinks like me so
um it's been awesome i'm just happy to
be in the south it feels like
this is where people are saying and i
mean
i'm i guess you can't really because you
weren't in la but daily wire was in los
angeles and
it really is the land of a living dead
when you're doing la in new york and dc
yeah i was living in pennsylvania uh you
had accused me of living in canada so
that was
you'd spread a rumor online that i lived
in canada internet spread that rumor and
i believed it
the internet spread it because you said
it no no it was it was q anon stuff
it was like matt walsh lives in canada
and i and i fell for it i don't know
internet's a dangerous place
to this day the worst insult anyone has
ever leveled at music being a canadian
so i want to talk about your show we'll
talk about your show in a minute but
first just to go over some of the stuff
happening in the news
um i want to get your thoughts on a few
of it uh i i guess we have to begin with
the royal family because that's what
everyone's talking about i know you've
been
i've been very vocal you've been on top
of it so i have two questions
um and and the first one is is a serious
question because i really i'm hoping you
can
shed some light on this why does anyone
care about these
god-awful people so we'll start with
that why do you think people care that
much
so i have to say i never had an
appreciation for the royals right it's
just it's something that americans don't
really jive with it never made sense to
me uh but i fell in love and married an
englishman right
and uh so i kind of learned to
appreciate the significance of the queen
and really understanding that there has
been there's been something in their
country
that has remained solid and has not
changed over time
difficult for americans to comprehend
because we are we don't really do
tradition we're kind of like tear it
down
old building turn it down tear it down
build something new tear it down build
something new
um so that's the reason i think people
follow the royals now
i i don't care at all for the harry and
megan thing except for the political
undertones of somebody saying
i'm not liked therefore it's because i'm
25
black like that that stuff bothers me
whether it's or you know we're talking
about
democrats saying it we see that
pollution all throughout hollywood so
this hollywood star
going into a country that really sort of
loves its traditions
uh and then accusing them of being
fundamentally racist it's just like
let's keep the american bs race
narrative at least within
within the bounds of america let's not
extend it overseas to europe because
they have a different culture there
they've been around much longer you know
england never had slaves
in its country and by the way in terms
of worldwide slavery the english men
were the first to abolish it so she
she's sort of relying on american
ignorance and the race obsession in
america and extending it
extending it overseas it's just it's
really bothersome
so do you think uh the american media
running to meghan markle's defense do
you think part of that is there
how they detest tradition in general and
so they they don't like the royal family
for that reason
yeah i mean think about where we are
right now in america like right that is
sort of this like cultural marxist
everything that is from yesterday is
wrong needs to be tore down everything
about america is wrong we got to get rid
of christopher columbus dr seuss is
racist
uh you know so we are just obsessed with
thinking that everything from the past
is wrong
and sure there were elements of the past
that were definitely wrong
but in many ways we've thrown out the
baby with the with the bath water
and um england is just a different place
right i mean
their population it's there's only three
percent black people in england it's a
remarkably you know
compared to america a very small country
um and so
it just sends it's just it's so ignorant
it's it's just the height of ignorance
to me
uh to have this d-list actress that
nobody knew
go over there not her race is not
discernible by the eye you if she walked
in
you would never say meghan markle is a
black woman right and then she says her
son who if you've seen a picture of
and you think that he has faced um
anti-black racism in his life then i'm a
nigerian prince and i have
you know an account that you can give
you can send some money into
um it's just it's just it's it's
frustrating i think we're just tired of
the race narrative
here in america and it's just obnoxious
that we sent this girl over here to
start
to start the same thing overseas yeah i
i'm glad you mentioned that
you said 25 black right is that is that
the actual
uh megan is le megan is less than 50
black her mother is half black yes she's
25
less than 25 black yeah yeah because i
had the same experience when we first
started hearing about her and we heard
that
this racism against a black woman my
first experience was that she's
is she a black woman yeah exactly so it
does make a little bit hard to believe
but it does it
i think doesn't it tell you something
about the way the victimhood
hierarchy works on the left and it's a
really confusing
intersectionality as you know is very
confusing but
the reason why this woman is able to
make a victim of herself
even though she's fabulously wealthy and
she's in her
18 000 square foot mansion
you know and she's got her netflix deals
and everything and she's sitting on a
patio
more expensive than my house and talking
to oprah and all that she's still the
victim
right um because she's less white than
the other ones right and so that it's
all about the intersectionality
yeah it's ridiculous and it's the same
thing i say to my husband so we i now
have a half black half
white son and i always say to my husband
is he half privilege or half a press
like what is he oppressed or privileged
you know this is sort of the weird
thing and it she never throughout her
life she never presented as black it
wasn't like she was playing black
characters who wanted people to identify
her as black
but it became convenient for her when
she realized okay the entire united
kingdom
hates me i'm not a very likable person
and the elements that they hated about
her are the elements that i think
conservatives say about hollywood
right where she just wanted to be the
center of attention at all times
and she couldn't respect tradition and
then she goes around and says okay well
how can i make the american press love
me since i've been sort of chased out of
the country because no one likes me
there and the obvious thing for her was
i'm in hollywood so i'm gonna take you
know the race narrative and it's just
pathetic you know
you're wealthy by the way even if you
weren't sometimes in life people don't
like you
i know google my name you know what i'm
saying i've got tons of hit pieces
against me
i've never once read those hit pieces
and said well it's clear they don't like
me because i'm black
you know sometimes people don't like you
deal with it how do you with a
victimhood hierarchy because i'm always
fascinated by this
we know that she can put herself on it
for the for the racial issue but
who are i can never quite figure out on
the left
who are the uber victims who's at the
top of the hierarchy
i think it's probably lgbt trans
is it is that what it is but it seems to
change depending on who
who the person is yeah it's weird so the
trans stuff what i've noticed is
it does seem like okay they are the
biggest victims
but that's actually not true because
black americans
by and large do not support the trans
agenda that's actually being pushed by
wealthy white people
um so it's it's very interesting to try
to discern even now when you see like a
big race scandal and you'll be like oh
this person was canceled because they
were racist
most of the time it's white people that
are canceling people it's not
black people that are up in arms like
black people did not go up in arms about
dr seuss that was literally created by
by white people who are now wielding the
the race sword and being like ah you
must go morgan wallin scandal
black people were like completely out of
the morgan is right i mean so they're
like
so this is actually white people being
empowered and using race as a tool and
white people establishing that the trans
agenda is now their new
frontier of oppression so um
no i don't think that i think black is
peak peak victim and if black americans
were like
cut this out with the trans stuff they
would have to sort of cut it out
um uh but yeah it's interesting because
really the question is is who's deciding
on these cancellations and these
victimhoods it ends up being if you
follow it
wealthy white corporations and of course
you add in the political ideology part
of it because
by that equation you should be able to
claim victory but you can't because
you're actually at the bottom
right because even though you're a black
woman you're conservative so right
you're like you become the uber villain
but also what's magical about it though
is they don't know how to defeat me
because in order to defeat me they'd
have to go against their own rules right
so they've decided that being a black
woman like i'm at the top of the
progressive stack right like
black women need to find their voices
like megan in her interview i guess
said um something about like i always
felt like the little mermaid who fell in
love with the prince and lost her voice
which is just one of the most
realistic she actually said that you see
what i mean like it just makes you
cringe and it makes you angry you're
just like
hollywood you're right is your mermaid
and it's like no like you found
a wealthy guy that could help you climb
a ladder because you were a d-list
actress
the end you won great walk away into the
into the sunset and be happy
um but yeah it's it's interesting you
don't know
how to attack me don't you find that you
get even more hate than let's say i
would as a white man oh yeah because
not only you're saying unpopular things
but also there's this element of
you're betraying the left thinks that
they should that you belong to them
right right so they get very frustrated
because it's like they
they assumed all this power by creating
these sort of victimhood channels and
one of those things was
black women are always victims when a
black woman denies
being a victim and says you know i i
don't want to take the victim card i
don't believe in the black card
um i feel remarkably privileged in this
country to be an american living and
breathing at this time you are you are
privileged
they just go oh because now they don't
know how to defeat me without
being racist themselves right because
attacking a black woman is fundamentally
racist so
they just want me to go away and they
don't know how to make that happen
we were talking about the trans thing a
second ago gender i've noticed it seems
like correct me from wrong but it seems
like you're
in recent months you've been focusing
especially on on gender issues yeah
going back to the infamous harry styles
your your controversial opinion that you
don't think men should wear dresses i
don't know how you could possibly say
such a thing
uh but so there's that and then there's
the women the men in sports and all
those sorts of things
i think that the gender issues have been
i've been saying for years that this is
one of the central battlefields of the
culture war it's time for conservatives
to wake up to it and
start engaging this is not a sideshow uh
it felt for
for so long the conservatives said well
yeah this is a
fad it'll go away it's not so what am i
correct that you've been
focusing on this more and if so why why
is this important do you think so i
actually haven't been focusing on it
more
it's just that it's kind of finally come
to fruition
uh which you you know you predicted i
predicted it so three
years ago when i was first speaking out
i was like watch this because this is
something that you think oh
oh it's less than one percent of the
population it's you know it's not going
to ever be a thing and i was like
i just kind of saw it kind of brewing
and i had done tons of episodes on my
show my previous shows talking about it
when i was sitting in college campuses i
was talking about it
and then it feels like sort of in the
last six months they sort of became
really obsessed with now even calling a
woman a woman is wrong right like even
trying to say
in all of these terms womanx how do you
even say it womex women's
womenics mixing mixing we're mixing
mixing we'll mix in yes right i also
thought
i thought it was le tinx but i'm told
that it's a latin x no let's go with the
tanks
right and which is hilarious because if
you ever use the word latinx it's the
easiest way to discern that someone is
not actually latino or latina because
they'd have to do away with the entire
language
everything is a gender in spanish la
mesa that's table like it's like boy or
girl for everything
um but yeah so i just saw it coming and
i wanted to really assert myself on that
issue because it is
i mean it is just the greatest undoing
trying to you get to a destroy families
weaken society i mean you can do
everything through the transgender
movement that the left is really
after which is just chaos um so yeah i
just spoke out against it and i will say
this
like i said earlier it is the one issue
that black americans are the most
uncomfortable with and so
i have not you know i've seen black
americans
across both sides of the political
spectrum say okay i'm this she's 100
right which makes sense because if you
pull black america in terms of their
politics they've never been
big supporters of the lgbtq
art
yeah whatever it is i just say the whole
alphabet but
you say that black americans don't
support this and i've i've
heard that before but you don't hear
that that voice the voice is heard
through you
but it's not they don't they don't have
very many um
outlets to express that i mean blm for
example
is at least before they scrub their
their page that you know laid out their
whole agenda the stuff about
tearing down the families yeah families
they took a lot of that stuff off but
before they took that stuff off you read
it and you thought well this is just a
this is an lgbt group this is
not there's very little here even about
race it's mostly about trans and
um so is that uh
why don't we hear that expressed more i
mean is it yeah
you know i think you do it's just not
given it's not given
air so like i definitely have heard
charlemagne the god
right on the breakfast club talk about
various political issues and he will
always give they will always side
on the candace is right on this one you
know and
and definitely throughout the harry
styles thing
actually it was the first time black
twitter ever came to my defense by the
way
as they call it hashtag black twitter um
because you know noah cyrus miley cyrus
apparently has a little sister and she
jumped in to defend harry styles
and in the process called me like a
nappy-headed hoe and then it kind of
went viral on instagram and they were
all talking about the issues saying that
this is this is just not something we
accept
but the media won't cover it so it sort
of exists in this bubble on social media
whereas i i know you speak to black
americans they never
ever ever have attacked me on my
position on women or women and men or
men
um and i think that they really see that
as an attack
on black men you know and it's tech it's
an attack on all men you know what it
means to be a man
and we already have so many issues when
it comes to father
fathers in the home and what it means to
be a man in black america as
is so it's just not something that
they're gonna get behind so it's a
losing issue
um for democrats which is why i'm okay
with them trying to force this down
people's uh throats because
in my opinion you start calling a black
woman's child
you know her son by a female name and
you're going to wake up
you know a sleeping a sleeping giant
yeah
i agree with you it's a losing issue i
think across most demographics yeah
uh it's just that again there's this
it's hard to get that voice
out there right because the media
doesn't want it doesn't want to air that
but
one of the things i want to ask before
we talk about your show on this topic
there's this gallup poll that came out
i don't know if you saw it last week i
think it was
um talking about the the rise of lgbt
identification in the younger generation
gen z and they're defining i think they
define that as 1990s
born between 1997 and 2002 or something
uh so
this this leaves out like our kids
generation and
even other other kids but um they found
in the gallup poll
that something like 12 of this
generation identifies as bisexual
he's like 10 times higher than other uh
older generations
the number of transgender uh
identifications 10 times higher
there there are now more trans
identifying people in gen z than there
are lesbians
uh now i got in some trouble on twitter
because i said that i think this is a
an active effort by the lgbt left
to essentially recruit kids to
indoctrinate kids into their
way of thinking yeah um what do you what
is your take on that
my take on that is first and foremost i
have realized as i said with the race
issue that a lot of the times it's not
black americans behind it it's not lgb
behind this transgender
you speak i've spoken to tons of people
that are on the left lesbian gays and
they are uncomfortable
with what they don't even understand why
they're being forced to
pretend to defend this i mean lgb really
has nothing to do with t
right and they've been able to amass a
lot of power pushed through policies
uh california just proposed a bill that
boys and girls sections that would make
boys and girls sections in retail stores
and online stores illegal and that
people that have signs that say boys
section girl section will get fined a
thousand dollars
right you can't tell me that gays and
lesbians got together and like this is
just unbelievable
um so there's there's something
political
that's pushing this and they're hiding
um behind the lgb people to try to push
that through
um which is interesting and it's super
alarming but in regards to
um children identifying which is
definitely happening
um they're being encouraged in the
school system so again there's something
coming down the political pipeline
that's encouraging them to see and then
you have these woke parents who are like
this is just who my child
is and what i always say is that if you
show me a trans
child it's like showing me a vegan dog
you know who's making the decisions
right it's just like my dog's a vegan no
your dog's not you know i mean
my child's trans so your child's not you
know you are you know
putting this lifestyle upon the child
because you just don't think i grew up
i've been
i've been a kid you don't think like
that when you're a kid you don't think
in terms
of sexual identification gender
identification you hardly even know what
the stuff even means you just kind of
want to
run around on a playground and have some
fun i was the ultimate tomboy when i was
um would probably say from six to
ten i was just like i just went hang out
the boys
just wanted to wear baggy clothes and
thank goodness
um that i grew up in the 90s because my
mother wasn't like well you're michael
you're obviously michael you know what i
mean they were just like your candice
going through a tomboy phase and then
you know when i got older suddenly i
thought those boys i was running around
the playground with were attractive
uh so these kids are not even being
allowed to grow up and their parents are
pitching holding them into these these
decisions which
if you grow up and you know allow that
to happen this is going to end up with
depression
suicide the rates are staggering for for
transgendered individuals who actually
transition
um and commit suicide thereafter there's
a lot of transitioning regret and it's
because they don't have parents
parenting you know and and that's sad
yeah to your point about this not being
an lgb thing but a tea thing
uh you know when you look at the numbers
the
the the l lesbians are being basically
erased in the younger generations
as we see the trans numbers go up and
it's also it's interesting you say as a
tomboy
uh you know if that if you were tomboy
now with some of the modern parents
they'd say you're trans and that's why
it's this is this irony where
um actually the left has made
gender a more rigid thing because now
it's actually
if you're a girl you're not allowed to
behave right like a boy because if you
do
now you become a boy right so for a long
time it seemed like they were saying
well just because let's let's open up
let's be more open-minded and if you're
a girl doesn't mean you have to play
with dolls you can play trucks too
i'm on board for that but now they've
they've kind of
contradicted themselves and they said
well come to think of it
if you're a girl playing with trucks
maybe you're actually a boy so right
yeah they've made it more rigid and
that's what i say in terms of race too
these things that they focus on they say
that they're trying to make things
better
they always worsen them you know it
wasn't an issue for girls to play with
guys if i was in the toy store and saw a
boy's signing the girls sign a i don't
even know if i was reading at the time
that i was going to toys r us which is
now extinct
um but secondly if i wanted to go into
the boilers out and grab something i'd
have just done it my parents never been
like
what are you doing in the boys aisle i
never felt traumatized that there were
like
you know they were filtering uh products
and by the way guys do they gravitate
towards different things my
my brother paid played with entirely
different things we wanted the barbies
it wasn't because of a gender construct
you know we wanted the barbies i wanted
to take care i wanted to pamper i wanted
a baby doll those maternal instincts
happen at such a young age
my um uh brother he wanted
video games he wanted trucks he wanted
things that i just wouldn't have played
with but nothing was stopping us
from playing with the other you know the
other toy certainly not our parents
yeah that's i my first kids were boy
girl twins
and you know you put you bring them to
the play room got all the toys
laid out and even at two years old they
tend to gravitate towards
their gender typical toys but it's not
like i'm standing there to my son
get your hands off that doll trucks are
for you son
yeah um now okay let's we got to talk
about your show that's that's that's
supposed to be the main topic here we've
gone off and i'm not a very good
interviewer i've taken us in
oh it's fine it's fun it's best when
they're just natural you know
uh so your your show is debuting soon
can you tell us
i i even even here i've been it's been
sort of like mysterious what is the
community very
serious i heard there's going to be an
audience i heard these kind of things so
what's uh can you tell us about the show
can you give us a lot of rumors
yeah um yeah so i think you know we kind
of just wanted to create something that
hasn't really been done before
for conservatives and it's the time is
super opportune right you have
minimally 80 million americans who just
feel like they're not being heard right
now
and uh who feel like they're being
castigated for their political views and
it also feels like we've been
increasingly shut out of culture like oh
we can't have
you know conservatives aren't allowed to
be funny they're not allowed to have
live audiences this is not a thing that
conservatives are allowed to do so we
are doing a live
uh live audience show and it will be
very much in the vein of a lot like a
lot of
the old school late night talk shows
when they were actually fun
right when they actually had a sense of
humor and they weren't so polarizing
um and done entirely at the expense of
half of the country
um and so i always say to people i
wanted to create something and it's it's
so funny to me to say this now but when
i was growing up i loved
chelsea lately before she went lefty
wacko couldn't take a joke and now she's
taking xanax to deal with the election
results
she was funny along once upon a time
chelsea handler was actually funny and
irreverent and had a sense of humor and
made fun of everyone
um and it was a feel-good show it had
you know had a panel
so there were elements that i really
loved and missed about having a woman
who could have a sense of humor and not
take herself so seriously
um first and foremost and just kind of
creating a show
that does still also have a real purpose
we're not sitting around talking about
celebrities like she was talking about
but we are talking about these sort of
really important political issues um
that are getting lost
because a lot of the times you know the
news cycle moves so quickly
that it's almost we're all 80d right one
second you're trying to talk about this
issue and then they've kicked it and
they're talking about this issue
and i really wanted to sort of um get
people focused on
these issues like we just talked about
in this show to really understand
what is happening in this country how
serious it is
but also to give them a message of hope
and that's through my monologue
and my epilogue what would you say at
the end when you say something at the
end epilogue maybe can't have a log
chart
but like no but like the opposite of an
epilogue is a prologue and i wouldn't
call them monologue the prologue well i
guess it's a monologue prologue
yeah and then it's a monologue epilogue
i just call it the monologue at the end
the simplest thing yeah
monologue at the end and and sort of
giving them a sense of hope
and and letting people know okay it does
kind of feel like the world's on fire
and we're just watching it burn um but
there there are some things to feel
hopeful about people are fighting back
people are winning
um and to invite you know for the
interview segment
americans you know of course there will
be some celebrities
um put onto the show as well but also
i'm inspired by a lot of americans that
are fighting back
students who are fighting back against
the indoctrination that's happening
at their schools and uh it's gonna be a
really fun show
that's bringing the hope into it is good
because i and that'll be good to eject a
little bit of sunlight here because i'm
just doom and gloom
that's my perspective some people like
to watch the world burn
right that's your show so but it it's i
think it's hard to inject
sometimes uh actual hope in a way that
is
that's that's real and substantive and
not superficial
right and to inspire people like i said
i you know i was reading a story about
these
literal i'm trying to get them on my
show but these catholic teens
who were going to school obviously at
the time of george floyd
george floyd protesting and when
everyone just went super awoke and
one of their classmates had gone back
and found old pictures of them
where the kid had acne in one picture he
had an all white face mask
next picture he had an all green face
mask with his two buddies and they just
said
that's blackface green mass acne mask he
actually had acne
the school that is insane he but he got
expelled and they and they said we know
you didn't actually do this
but it's very important for us to send a
political message right now in this time
incredible he got expelled they said you
either yeah you either withdraw we're
gonna expel you and his parents withdrew
and then lawyered up and are suing and
are actually winning
right and so that's kind of the message
people need to hear
because i always get these questions of
like what can i do what can i do fight
you gotta fight this is not a time now
to say what can i do
your parents you gotta fight for your
students you gotta go in you gotta march
into the doors
if they do something crazy like that
well it's just it's an important message
for us to send that ewing green face is
in fact
not okay you know because george floyd
died and it's what what world are we
living in
um so kind of like those stories talking
to these teens talking to these parents
parents need to see that and say
wow they won you know and and um
know that they can do that too it's very
easy you don't need to always look to
your political heroes and say
and figure out what you can do it's
going to start on the it's going to
start at the ground level or it's not
going to happen
you know well we're all excited for the
new show
um and uh thanks for joining us candace
thanks for having me yeah absolutely